thank you so much for coming along I
hope you find this talk interesting I
actually gave my first public talk at
NDC tech town last year and so I was
really really pleased to get the email
to be invited back so I hope you enjoy
it and what I'm going to talk about and
this is just a kind of taster of what's
coming later so this is the thing called
the Bloomberg terminal which is a
basically a trainer workstation that's
all over the the trading clause of the
world and this is this is a real-time
analysis of the UI thread this is
actually running right now and we're
going to we're going to talk about what
this means and how we how we get there
and how we actually make a system that
runs reasonably fast it this also gives
you a scale of the data that's that's
coming in you know these are these are
new story headlines that are being
generated in real time right now so this
isn't like Twitter you know behind each
one of these there is a story which may
have media it may have pictures you may
have deep analysis but this is this is
how they're coming in from you know all
over the world and this is just you know
mostly human generated news
there's also actual real-time financial
data which is in orders of magnitude
more than that but it just gives you a
sense of the fact this is a very dynamic
kind of place for data anyway coming
back to that to that later on
okay so going away right okay
so as I said welcome I'm Paul Williams I
work at Bloomberg in in London mainly
and this is a talk about how we design a
desktop platform for near real-time
financial data and how we go about
measuring how this thing is actually
behaving so the agenda is really talking
about this terminal I'm talking about
one of the the core systems embedded
into this terminal called data layer
which is a layer that processes data
we're not so good at names for things
I'm also going to talk about embedding
chromium and pretty much all of our GUI
is rendered using open source chromium
embedded browser core and I'm talk about
what that means in in a in our world I'm
gonna talk about instrumentation the
kind of principles we use to measure how
things are behaving how we actually
assess slowness if the user says this
feels slow what does that actually mean
how we record and playback what's going
on so we can actually generate
reproducible and kind of in test cases
and also some of their current research
we're doing into web assembly I know
that really the one of the first times I
heard about webassembly was actually at
this conference last year when addy
Chabot was talking about cross-platform
development he grabbed a break talk
including how you can actually
incorporate C++ into into a browser
platform and it's something we've been
looking at very very intently anism
produced some very interesting and
intriguing results so far so am i very
quickly I will white trousers in the 80s
I learnt most of my kind of how
computers work from actually programming
at very early sort of music sequences
for live used in the university bar I
did some work in the games industry I
then spent nine years doing kind of a
traditional full-stack which was
basically from the firmware you know up
through devoted drivers operating
systems port and compilers and one
custom parallel processing hardware who
remembers the i860 probably nobody in
this room it was a at the time it was he
was the fastest floating-point processor
I've been involved in actually
up teams in some of our other offices
around the world and this is our San
Francisco meetup space that we have and
the last 20 years I've been working at
Bloomberg primarily involved in the
desktop side actually which is very much
the world of high-performance C++ and
nowadays integration with JavaScript as
a scripting environment within the same
processes and I'm a manager developer
still like to think of myself as a
developer mentoring in in our offices
and I'm in a very very passionate about
seeing the next generation do this stuff
and more and you know improving
diversity and actually seeing us be more
kind in this industry which I see a lot
happening particularly at conferences
like this it's really really wonderful
to see so a first stage Bloomberg
terminal what is it
it's from the if you ask one of our
product or salespeople it's a financial
business data analytics portal
connecting the most influential people
in this field what makes it interesting
that it's near real-time it's not just
you know static financial reports and so
on multi window multi-screen some
traders have 8 HD or 4k monitors a lot
of pixels to update built using hybrid
desktop technologies a lot of C++ a lot
of integration with JavaScript a lot of
JavaScript code actually and embedding
chromium and the way we think of it is a
cluster of 300,000 desktop computers
that we can't see we can't touch we
really care about we really care about
how they behave and they're not only
running our software they're running
other people's software as well so we
have to be really good citizens the
restaurants not like programming an Xbox
or a PlayStation where you can kind of
take over the machine and nobody else
cares when you're when you're running a
game and users expect it to be fast and
reliable it's not cheap there it's a
high quality service and what's going on
inside and our server side which I'm not
really going to talk about I'm just
going to touch on it here we have
obviously application engines they've
got a lot of our business logic and we
have continuously running data services
now some some data is actually prices
overnight to be ready for the next day
and at one point we actually were using
GPU farms to do some of this work
because if we if we for example ran a
Monte Carlo simulation
using traditional hardware it wouldn't
finish on time we just couldn't scale it
so we actually found that you know GP
for mortgage calculations kind of sounds
a little bit odd but actually it really
it really helps us and then we have a
real-time database which we call the
ticket plant which is the thing that is
is feeding out real-time updates you
know it can be up to 100 billion updates
a day sometimes 10 10 million updates in
the in the first second of one of the
New York exchanges actually opening we
have a kind of network to do what you
deliver this data out to our clients
around the world and then we have these
terminals running in this kind of
environment this is the New York Stock
Exchange for example many banks and so
on have you know have have these
terminals so it's a pretty simple
architecture with a few you know a few
little interesting details so if we you
know think of a typical impanel function
so what you know somebody people like
the keyboard and in our world very much
you know somebody will run what's called
an in panel function there would be data
coming from our servers to populate this
screen and then it will open a
subscription that will then feed
real-time data in a push fashion down to
the desktop and then much of the
interaction will go on purely on the
client side while real-time data is
still flowing and then you know this you
know so we try and limit to our server
interactions as much as we can but
obviously when you try and do something
new you're going to have to go back to
our servers on the on the back end
looking inside this what's actually
going on there traditionally and this is
where I did a lot of my own development
and through the years was actually a
fully you know purely homegrown UI stack
written in C++ which served us well for
quite a lot of years but it kind of you
know every time you've got a roll out
new software to actually change anything
it's not so great so we did introduce we
actually got some PlayStation developers
on the team and they brought this little
thing called Lua and very very
lightweight scripting engine which is
our first foray into I'm actually doing
scripting within the desktop product
within the infrastructure layer and
there again that served us quite well
but it was fast but relatively
inflexible because
everything was you know the the the look
and feel was compute coded in c++ for a
long time more recently we've come up
with a much more flexible scalable model
where we have multiple processes to
start with and run indistinct
applications much more geared to modern
hardware where you've got multiple cores
in a machine and we've got a far more
flexible render subsystem and it kind of
looks the same but that's intentional
you know we now have the capability to
make it look like anything but for many
of our users they basically wanted to
look like a little 30 years ago you know
with more powerful analytics and and
much wider breadth of data but you know
many many users still you know kind of
like to use it in the way they have been
using it before so if we if we dive a
little bit deeper what do we find inside
one of these application container
processes there's obvious um management
layer going on data subscription is you
imagine as you might imagine there's
going to be this thing called data layer
which I'm going to dive into in a moment
an application engine and then beneath
that kind of underpinning all of this we
have the embedded chromium subsystem
which which comprises the browser core
and the v8 JavaScript engine beneath all
this which is really very much where my
my technology passion is is the the
metrics subsystem so thinking about how
this whole thing fits together and
people often ask you to know what just
use the web for this you know surely the
web nowadays is is good enough the web
is still primarily request response you
know asynchronous Ajax related stuff is
obviously you know that you know
surprise that's all initially and then
became incredibly popular it still
currently doesn't beat you know being
able to push real time data at the same
time as handling a kind of request
response service and we're finding you
know for some of our data processing
we're not quite at the stage where a
browser is is fast and efficient enough
for us you know typical Bloomberg user
experience might involve you know 10 to
50,000 updates per second across you
know 100 or sometimes 200 and top-level
windows on the desktop from only 2d
grids and charts so you know good
GPU accelerators don't really help us
that much lots of flying texts complex
visualizations in some cases but with
live data and it's common to have you
know orders of magnitude more rows
off-screen then you can actually see you
know I might have a hundred thousand
trade orders in my blotter but I only
want to see the 20 that are most
relevant to me right right this second
so there is a need for a high
performance native processing layer and
alongside the the UI which is what we're
going to talk about next so data layer
kind of fits in here in the in the
scheme of things what is it it's a pure
a fully programmable fully implemented
in C++ near real-time streaming data
transformation engine integrated with
the other components and with Crimean
via via the a JavaScript engine much
like a browser if you were if you're a
traditional web developer you might want
to hook up to indexdb or local storage
services which are implemented natively
in the browser but the things that you
can actually access from your familiy
javascript this the data script
subscription module brings in the the
pushed real-time data into this into
this world based on programmable rules
that can be set by our application teams
so inside this this data layer component
well this is really just a set of
building blocks that we can that an
application developer can piece together
to form this the streaming pipeline so
we have a thing called work sheet which
is analogous to Excel basically if
you're you know you can you can express
it so like expressions primarily you
know per column rather than individual
cells or you can actually do it any way
you like and it also supports hooking up
to the subscription layer we have
obviously components they can do things
like filtering sorting based on what can
be quite complex criteria and a
component call the data source which is
really a an engine that using templates
can transform numerical and string data
into the formats you actually want to
see on the screen with all the sort of
formatting rules that you might want to
apply to actually get the data into the
into the GUI so
seeing you tend to set it up as a
rules-based system and let it run for
your particular application use case you
can do more with it so for example you
can combine data together you might have
streaming data coming through your
worksheet combined with some reference
data in another table that you want to
show together within a particular piece
of the GUI or you might want to split it
so you know the same data pipeline might
be driving something like a you know a
trading blotter and a trading ticket and
maybe some kind of chart so you can you
can hook these these things together in
any way that makes sense you can build
trees we have something called
aggregation view which transform this
data into trees with partial sums and
averages at each node and so on row
history view for example if you if
you've got streaming news headlines
coming in you might want to turn that
into a 2d representation in as each
headline comes in so you can actually
display that in some kind of scrolling
URI with history roll back and so on to
actually program and understand this
pipeline we have a thing called data now
inspector which is actually written in
JavaScript and allows you to understand
what's going on inside this pipeline and
you think this looks kind of crazy for
this this kind of display but you know
there's going to be lots of rules
embedded here which allow this display
to handle all the nuances of different
kinds of trades that may happen that
allowed me to maybe drill down into this
system and do you know interesting
things without having to go back to this
to the server you know this is going to
be a lot of state held in this in this
system in a specifically for this kind
of application how do we make it fast
and how do we make it run efficiently in
a small footprint and there's a few
things we have something called datum
which I'm going to talk about for a
moment we make use of polymorphic
allocators now of course I'm from
Bloomberg I have to mention allocators
sorry about that but there you know that
it's something that that really helps us
and now that they are you know there's
this new polymorphic alligator in the
standard in C++ 17 it's it's something
that we really feel it's we really want
to show the world how we how we've used
them because it's actually very easy and
it for us it really really helps us
some of the optimization tricks we
actually use with the sort of within the
data layer infrastructure to to minimize
CPU usage so why might we want around
custom data types within each grid cell
because we have bridge like this now
something like this is a we call it a
worksheet component you know a user
might have 20 30 of these on the screen
at the same time probably not sorted by
time because that's fairly useful
useless but I thought I'd give you a an
idea of the data and what you can't
really see here is there's probably you
know that there's going to be tens of
thousands of rows of this data and maybe
hundreds of columns because you know a
lot of the again the nuances of how this
data needs to be displayed and the rules
for processing it is often done in
off-screen equations so the numbers add
up you know so if I've got for example
it you know maybe a worst case 100,000
rows of data with 300 columns even if
each cell is only represented by one
double and it's gonna be more than that
usually because there's going to be
other other data associated with each
cell that would be 240 megabytes of data
and if you know our data type for a Cell
doubled in size that's another two
hundred forty megabytes so it matters it
matters you know paying attention to the
detail at this at this level so what is
datum datum is a compact bit wise bit
wise got people variant type a trivial
unoptimized implementation would look
something like this where there's a
union of all your different cut things
it can be and something that allows you
to select which of those it currently is
but me is that you there's quite a lot
of waste in here partly through you know
having that extra Union type field
partly through alignment issues
typically so for example you know this
is holding a double then it's you know
is even if type is only a few bits this
thing is probably going to end up being
16 bytes in this kind of implementation
because because of alignment so that's
as we've just shown that's not ideal so
can we do better now you know ideally
we'd want to do something like this you
know is there any way we can actually
overlay the type somehow in into the
data and you think well that's not gonna
work because you're going to be trashing
your actual data by putting the the type
in there however you look at all these
data types particularly on a 32-bit
platform only double uses the whole
thing if the whole eight bytes so all
the rest actually have a few bits pair
in the pointers obviously would only be
32-bit in the in this particular example
the others generally you can keep
smaller than the full eight bytes so is
there anything we can do here well who
remembers I should believe
floating-point format from their their
days of at school or college all right
so I kind of had to refresh myself on
this as well what's one of the
interesting things about this you know
I'm sure you'll remember you have the
significant which is the numeric part
and then really the son of scale factor
it's the exponent you know how you know
where this is actually in reality and
the sign on the end just so happens
there is it there's a whole range within
the possible bit patterns here which
represent the signaling nan Valley so if
you get a nan which means not a number
it's the excuse why isn't this a number
what's what's the reason for this not
being a number but in many real-world
scenarios you don't really know need to
know that the reason I've got not a
number you just need to know it's not a
number because probably you're going to
display blank or error or something like
that so if we sacrifice all the distinct
nan values except one which we used to
represent generic cannot a number we can
actually use these bit patterns or some
of them for our type if we're careful
and it's kind of a little bit naughty
code but it does work so we can
effectively remove a separate field from
this from this Union and kind of overlay
these these distinct types into these
spare values with inside double you
might be feeling this is disgusting it
actually obviously you know if you
surround this by a serious set of unit
tests and you know really test
everything out of it you can be pretty
sure this is going to work
you know and if that's exactly what we
we do it's a little bit more tricky
because you kind of have to move
everything else around so that you know
things like you know the pointer kind of
aligns correctly so it doesn't actually
trash those bits and so on but you can
make it work and not only that you can
even end up storing music as a short
string optimization if you've got
strings which are only up to six bytes
you can actually accommodate those in
line and actually we find in reality
there are a lot of strings in the world
that are pretty short so you can
actually keep this as a very very
lightweight bitwise copyable small data
structure that kind of does most of the
things a variant and do one of our
colleague engineers from New York
actually gave a talk at CPP Khan last
year which is which is here I'm happy to
send round links and to anybody who's
interested afterwards so another thing
we do is we make use of PM are
polymorphic allocators so for those that
don't know about this this thing yet we
all know c++ is typical c++ memory use
is very dynamic you know the language
supports incredibly powerful complex
data structures which need to grow in
all kinds of different ways so heap
operations are going to be inevitable so
I have an example here where I've just
got it using a set the fact that the set
just has a you know a new unique unique
entry for each value you give it I'm
using it to count the number of unique
characters in a string that I give it
the set itself is on the stack here
that's great but it's going to reach out
to the heap in order to build its own
internal data structures and in order to
which is typically a tree and that could
potentially result in a in a large
number of heap allocation which we all
know can be can be slow heap allocations
sometimes lock sometimes they result in
fragmentation you know they're very
complex algorithms but they don't always
deliver data fast also they're not so
great for cache access because heaps
tend to give you pointers from one over
the place so how can we easily make you
make more use of stack or contiguous
heap in dynamic data structures and the
focus is on the easily here
C++ standard library has always had
allocators the the so it's always been
possible to do this it's just being one
of those situations where you end up
getting those horrible long template
errors which take your ages to to decode
it's it's never been a nice thing to do
and and it's actually put a lot of
people off I think actually really
really doing this and some of the
problems are you know once you start to
do this if you have two different custom
allocators a string type with declaring
one allocator is a different type from
one do declare with another type of
allocator
which is annoying if often what you just
want to do is say well here's a
container you use this allocator for
everything inside you and it's it can be
tricky to do that also you end up
proliferating template arguments kind of
all the way down into your functions
because you're now dealing with all
these customer types everywhere not not
nice so c++ 17 STL supports an
alternative approach which actually
bloomberg as you probably know have been
involved in developing polymorphic
memory sources so this is a custom
allocator that can be specified at
runtime without it being part of the
type so strings of your strings vectors
vectors maps are just maps regardless of
allocator the allocator is automatically
propagated to nodes and the internal
objects in the and these implementations
of the containers that support the
polymorphic allocator which is which is
neat and you don't have to worry about
this template proliferation all the time
so how does this work the c++ 17 STL
defines this interface for a new kind of
allocator which you can very easily
build your own allocators from and all
you really have to do is override du
allocate doodie allocate and du is equal
du is equal just it's just allowed to
allow you to say well my allocate if i
if you use my allocator for allocating
some data you can use this allocate
other allocator to free it it's a it's a
it's a helpful thing I've never actually
needed that but it's a it's in the
standard and for backward compatibility
there is a thing
polymorphic allocator which is the thin
wrapper around a pointer to PM RM
resource for backward compatibility with
the old standards so you can actually
plug this into the old containers if you
need to visual studio if you're using
Windows have this in production from
2017 onwards and my understanding is Lib
C has it in still in experimental that
information may be a little bit out of
date now I'm primarily working on the
Windows platform so let's see how this
thing actually works and also how easy
it is to use I think that is maybe not
the more important point that I'd like
to I'd like to make so here we are
here's my new example code it's going to
take this roughly 80 character string
and find out how many unique characters
are in this so before we do that we kind
of need to be able to understand the
behavior and observe it so I'd like to
be able to write a custom allocator that
just counts for me hopefully this would
one day be in the standard I'd like to
write a custom and okay to plug it into
my set a runtime because that's easy now
and then just see what happens so how do
I write that allocator
this is basically it I just had to
override to allocate and deallocate and
all I'm doing is keeping track of how
much I've currently got allocated how
many allocations I've done and what the
maximum size I ever hit was so my team
do allocate and deallocate and function
so the actual allocations are just going
to be whatever is passing by the parent
which by default is going to be the
default allocator which eventually calls
malloc and free so who wants to guess
how many times we're going to call
malloc when I run this for this roughly
80 character string handy there one time
any other one okay this is true this is
run with full optimization release mode
build 86 allocations
surprising right Wow
and but then you think about what
actually what's going on every time I
pass a string in a string character in
as we're to wait around I'm if it's a if
it's a unique character I'm having to
add a new node within this tree inside
the set and if the sets not being
particularly smart it's going to just
call mal up to make space for that node
each time round plus some extra
housekeeping - the times when we
actually duplicate characters but yeah
it's surprising right so nice and neat
code but not the best in terms of
performance in this case thirteen point
three microseconds so introducing the
monotonic buffer resource which people
might know as and there are sequential
allocator there's all kinds of other
words for this and allocator that when
you allocate it just advances a pointer
along any buffer that you give it when
you di locate it does absolutely nothing
so in this case when I a locate 24 bytes
I get a allocate another factor to I get
B when I delete a I completely do
nothing when I ask for C 8 characters I
get it from here as if a you were still
in use very very fast can use lots of
memory but very very fast I can just
plug this in and to see what happens so
if I if I plug this in very easy to
cascade so I've now got my accounting
memory resource which is think the thing
that really calls malloc and free is
going to be plugged into my monotonic
buffer resource so when it needs memory
it gets it from my counting allocated
which gets it from the system and I'm
going to pass that to the set see what
happens so hurrah
we've done better eight allocations four
and a half times faster already the
reason for this is that the monotonic
buffer resource itself will grab data in
chunks it doesn't actually it basically
says well I'm gonna have it you know a
reasonable size of buffer that I'm going
to get i'm gonna i'm then going to use
maybe i need to extend eventually and it
would end up extending eight times in
this was seven more times in in this
case so this is a great improvement
we're still eventually going to the heap
eight times but it's a it's a great
improvement can we do even better well
based on the kind of work we know we're
going to be doing let's actually give it
a bit of a hint and so well actually
what you get when you first start up on
a sunny buffer resource why not grab 4k
of data yes there's a little favor we
just giving you the favor so now what
happens we run this one allocation it
goes for that 4k that's all it needs
so we've shaved off a little bit more
time now you think we can do even better
any suggestions at the back there I line
it I think it's probably going to be
aligned anyway actually I know Victor
know the answer I go behind right great
so if we use the stack you think trivial
change right it's going to make much
difference let's run it zero allocations
because the monitor clear buffer
resource has no idea where that date has
come from you know if you if you give it
a size it'll allocate some if you give
it a buffer it'll just use it so we give
it a buffer to other happy that buffer
is it would extend if it needs to but in
this particular and hopefully the common
use case it literally uses the stack
allocated on the stack is really fast
you've literally move the stack pointer
this is local to the thread so there's
no need for any thread local storage or
locking or anything like that this is
literally the stack so if you know what
your code is doing something like a
monotonic buffer resource is really
really helpful you can get it wrong you
know you can easily end up you know
looping with one of these things and you
end up using huge amounts of memory but
if you really understand what your
algorithms are doing and then this can
really help but the point I'm really
trying to make here is not so much
monotonic buffer resource which is a
great tool but the fact it's so easy
it's so easy to plug these allocators in
question just there the the monotonic
buffer resource itself will extend so if
if you yeah it will go LLL go to heap
well it will go to its parent allocator
so you could cascade things in fact
example here is actually these are these
are the the pre-canned allocators you
get the null one is interesting which is
great for tests if you want to prove
that your your code is not making any
real heap allocation to plug in a null
memory resource and it will assert if if
you try and do any but they're also
pools which can be thread safe or not
you know here I'm actually building a
heat effectively at what a pool on the
stack so here's my monotonic buffer
resource using the stack and then I'm
actually cascading and unsynchronized
pool because he doesn't need any thread
safety for data within this thread on
top of that so it's kind of a stack
based pool requiring no locks but
probably lots of memory so interesting
so try it you know it's I think it's a
it's a real refreshing update to what
we've had for for a long time so I'm now
going to quickly talk about how we make
data layer algorithms themselves run a
little bit faster using a few techniques
so imagine a worksheet and we're going
to be currently displaying these three
rows on the screen so as these rows
update obviously we're going to have to
do any calculation and formatting and
get them on the screen if the scroll
position changes we're going to only
throw the the rows we need to the
display the concept of virtual grids is
known pretty well you know that's how
many UI systems work however what
happens if we sort the change column
over here we only need these three
security and price rows but knowing
which three rows we needs depends on us
evaluating the entire sorted column so
we have this concept not only of
windowing rows but actually having non
view portable columns so there are the
minimum set of the columns that you need
to fully evaluate in order to decide
what should be on the screen so this
kind of you know collection of we call
them windows within the data allow us to
still doing minimum amounts of work to
update the screen obviously in a small
example like this it doesn't make much
difference
but once you've got you know huge
numbers of columns and large numbers of
rows it really really helps
something else that we we do is we try
and not do work within worksheet
expressions as much as possible so you
know and you find that actually the kind
of expressions people put in these
worksheets particular application teams
they're not just you know like this one
asked - beard for example maybe it
should be past - beard that's right they
can be machine generated you know
expressions with tens of thousands of
characters in them sometimes it's we've
been quite surprised how enterprising
some of their application teams can be
so what we'd like to do is actually just
mark cells dirty until they're actually
required so in these two cells update in
the bid column we mark their
dependencies dirty but we don't actually
evaluate them until we really need them
so at some point the UI is well the you
arts going to be told there's an update
it's going to come back and say that the
rows and columns it needs and in this
case it's only going to calculate the
top one it does actually need the next
one so we have a system where we we try
and minimize the amount of work we do
all the time another thing we do is
update coalescing so you can imagine if
this is a trading blotter not only a
price is going to be changing but new
orders are going to be coming in all the
time resulting in row inserts and
deletes and moving things around and so
on so here we've got maybe an important
order coming to the top we're going to
insert a new one that's coming in we're
gonna update the values in that one
we're going to now delete two row
because it's become stale maybe and this
is going to obviously be a lot more
complicated there's a very simple
example but they're all going to be
these continuous stream with operations
going on if we choose to sort of package
some of them together we can actually do
more efficient operations and in this
particular case we could just the result
of those four operations can be more
simply done by just deleting one row and
certainly new your own updating it and
so we've actually in this case just
reduce the number of operations by one
in reality it can be
large percentage of operations can be
coalesced and reduced I think okay so
far everybody's still still here
embedding chromium I'm going to talk
about just for a moment going back to
the the picture of the application
container process what's actually going
on in here so we have these sort of
fundamental pieces as I said we used to
have this sort of homegrown C++ UI it
was very fast and efficient but it
needed programmers to change anything in
it and you could kind of tell that the
UI was built by programmers it wasn't
prettiest thing in the world it didn't
have any of the attention to detail that
the graphics designers and proper UX
experts can bring to things
inventing chromium brings us the full
richness of html5 css3 and JavaScript so
graphic designers can now use tools
standard tools to actually build pieces
of the of the UI even though this isn't
actually a web app and it's not just
looking for what actually behaviors so
nice rollover effects and so on and in
animations and all these kind of things
if they're needed we get a few things
for free as well the renderer itself
building to chromium supports hardware
acceleration GPU acceleration which is a
nice thing not to have to implement
yourself
things like accessibility integration
you know there are platforms within
Windows in our case to allow third-party
tools to that are there for example for
people who have slight difficulties to
you know to read out the text in the UI
you know in a way that allows them to
navigate an even trade and by embedding
chromium and using that UI layer we get
a lot of that for free which again is a
really really nice thing to to have to
do it's amazing seeing somebody actually
trading with the screen switched off
absolutely wonderful and to see that and
you know people who have they would
typically have real challenges can can
use our system in that and that sort of
way
javascript is required to update the Dom
you know we tried when we were first
experimenting you know directly going in
C++ straight into
which kind of works but you end up with
the consistent and inconsistent view of
the of the UI world from your JavaScript
and it just got us into into a big mess
so we settled on it is design we're
really you have to go via JavaScript to
get to the DOM and you might think oh
that's going to be really slow but
actually I as a super-fast
programmer I'm continually surprised how
fast modern JavaScript can run in one of
these modern engines it's pretty
impressive the jitters in there
sometimes do you know we often do
surprisingly well and it's because they
have a lot more context than maybe a
compiler or C++ might have a compile
time like you know they can really
understand what really hot code right
now and and optimize incredibly well for
that you know
so yeah the what the world has been
changing it's it's really interesting so
this is kind of how the whole thing fits
together we still have a native C++
layer but some bindings that allow us to
efficiently and plug in to JavaScript we
also have some extra services that allow
us to do screen management to access you
know in a protected way some system
resources that we do want to expose into
the JavaScript world and you know we
actually have you know various kind of
protection levels to you know allow us
to control actually what is what is
allowed to be used plus the fact that
the embedding engine itself supports you
know proper sandboxing on to the OS so
what are some of the challenges to make
this work really really well as I said
we kind of have to use the Dom to update
JavaScript to write efficient JavaScript
we actually use tools to help us a lot
we have booting to our CI and deployment
systems pipelines that actually do a lot
of pre optimizing of JavaScript using an
industry an industry standard tooling
module inlining minification dead code
elimination and so on get rid of all the
comments you know you don't need you to
keep remembering that this stuff is
actually gonna be interpreted when it
first hits the hits the the desktop
system
and you know introducing discipline to
JavaScript really helps when building a
JavaScript infrastructure layer you know
something that we actually sponsored
with the ECMO standard committee is
private class rules in JavaScript so
having the concept of private data in
your in your outer ap is that actually
anywhere within JavaScript but we you
know so that people can't abuse the API
is that you you give them quite a
contentious subject you know some
JavaScript developers want to do
anything in JavaScript but actually
having this support in the language and
is really really helping us and also we
are migrating to typescript which just
brings in a kind of an infrastructure
style discipline to writing a script
style code and now that can leverage
these natively supported private class
fields and that's something that we're
actually contributing back to the to the
the the the groups are build and
maintain the tools as I say javascript
is actually pretty fast
so often the efficient needs the the
focus needs to be on efficient
marshalling to and from JavaScript so we
spent a lot of time making things like
our datum data type Marshall very
efficiently across that boundary
minimizing GC you know welcome to GC for
anybody who's you know only does C++
it's a whole interesting new world
jaesi algorithms nowadays are actually
garbage collection by the way and for
anybody who doesn't know that
terminology has really evolved over the
years very sophisticated now JavaScript
engines will do a lot of the scanning
phase actually in background threads but
at some point we'll need to synchronize
with the main thread doing the the
JavaScript work and you really want to
be careful particularly this is the UI
thread to not have you know a stutter
enos on the screen just because GC is
happening so really the objective is to
minimize GC it doesn't always just
happen when your JavaScript heap is full
and it needs to actually free space
these engines tend to want to do GC
anytime they feel oh there's some
cleanup to be done because I've got a
lot of temporary objects so and we can
find that even in efficient code
that kind of goes in and out of the hot
sort of hot path and gets cheated and D
opted and back and forth results in
extra GC because objects containing code
are being continually created and
destroyed so something you have to be
really really watchful of and often you
know the sign of an efficient running
system is when GC is low and even if
you're not using that much memory so
it's it's a very interesting measurement
life cycle obviously with GC you've got
non-deterministic life cycle of objects
if you're right in pure JavaScript the
engine handles it really really well
however we've got this hybrid model
where you know many of our JavaScript
objects are going to be managing native
C++ objects and of course life cycle has
to be preserved across that boundary for
things to work so what we find is that
native C++ objects can end up living
much longer than we might expect them to
so here's my application I'm gonna you
know run run it through once produce
some stuff on the screen maybe I'm going
to have a JavaScript proxy object that
is backing my native C++ data layer
pipeline for example now I'm going to
you know click on a button and because
I'm running maybe a react style model
where you know changing a little piece
of data rebuilds a whole chunk of the
the the object tree that I'm going to be
rendering so we get a new object created
backing and another native data layer
pipeline which might be quite big we're
at the mercy of the GC engine now you
know the old object which we no longer
need may still exist you know there's no
reason there's no guarantee that the the
JavaScript engine is going to destroy
that first object so we may end up using
much more memory on the nature side than
we we want to ideally so what can we do
about that something we actually
borrowed from C sharp is the dispose
pattern where you can introduce
deterministic lifecycle of expensive
components even in a GC environment so
what I would do is actually write in my
code in JavaScript at the point where I
know I'm finish
with an object even though it may still
exist for longer call dispose which we
can proxy through to actually you know
releasing the final reference on to our
underlying C++ object and actually more
deterministically control the lifecycle
of things happening down at this level
some purists say you know you shouldn't
need that level of detail we're
engineers you know sometimes you have to
make these compromises and move away
from the sort of the purest approach you
know we've actually talked to the the
teams at Google about you know is the
more country you know can we give a hint
to an object that it really it it's
expensive it although it's a cheap
JavaScript object it backs something
expensive but generally the solutions
we've come up with have not really been
general enough to actually fix into the
to the engine so this is the the sort of
current approach we we take which to be
honest works pretty well for us so
instrumentation are we doing for time a
little bit left getting towards the end
it's really important for us to
understand what's actually going on
within this when in this system and
there are very you know obvious things
we can measure we can measure CPU load
we can measure memory utilization the
slightly harder things to understand or
measure are things like Headroom use or
it particularly user responsiveness what
it how does this system actually feel to
to an end user and these are some of the
things we we do so CPU load pretty
obvious we can ask the OS how busy a
process is how busy a thread is we also
have this concept of busyness which is
really and using elapsed time
measurements how long we spend doing a
certain types of activity during a
sample period you know how long do we
spend actually in the in the chromium
render how long do we spend processing
incoming data how long do you spend
updating a updating a worksheet
calculation and together these really
give us a good indication of where this
isn't spending its time even when you
can't afford to run a profiler in a full
profiler and also give us a good
indication of spare capacity it also
tells us things
you know high busyness using a lap time
but low load indicates weight or even
time slicing you know we might be
running on a on a VM which is you know
as you know there may be at the end
that's supplying you know eight users
but it's maybe it's only got four cores
you know so something's got to give
there and we can we can actually measure
these these kind of things and these are
the sort of tools you know I would use
to look at my own terminal to understand
how its behaving the white line is
overall CPU load on my PC you can see
why I ran a compiled the software this
is this is the Bloomberg app you know
bubbling away at the bottom and this is
telling me you know a breakdown of my
different layers in my in my Bloomberg
system so this is the kind of core
manager process in grey this blue thing
is is instant bloom like it's an
interesting messaging chat system which
we originally built for our own use
showed it to clients they loved it and
we now see clients with three or four
hundred chat rooms open at a time
actually trading through through the
chat room it's because it's considered
so reliable there's this community at
300,000 people that can instantly chat
to each other within this secure
environment and everything is you know
compliant you know everything's logged
you know so it's a in a very well
respected system so another view which
is kind of interesting is a 3d view I
asked the team to build this and they
said why Jim what 3d it's just purely
gratuitous right never going to be
useful but actually I find it is useful
you know the green here is our main
process the light blue is light instant
messaging process there's a few other
background things churning away for a
while and then I can see these other
little things that pop up occasionally
which a little in some cases of the
management tasks that it may be making
sure that my JavaScript is up-to-date
there's no there's been no you know
emergency fixed release or you know
other kind of things that wake up which
maybe I would never really notice in a
2d view and equally we can uh we can
look at memory memory is really critical
for us not only overall memory usage on
the machine but per process you know we
tend to run 32-bit processes people
people think why why partly is because
of the the size of these
grid cell objects you know if we move to
to a 64-bit platform suddenly pointers
get a lot bigger so if these these
objects like the datums are having to
now sometimes hold pointers - long
strings suddenly the thing has got a lot
bigger and which may not be an issue you
know we can't control how much RAM our
clients have on their desktops so we
have to be quite conservative if you
know we'd love to go 64-bit throughout
and I really hope we'll get that
opportunity we might have to make some
tricks like maybe you know assuming that
we don't use the full 8 8 byte address
space in pointers which not sure I want
to do that that might be even more
extreme than you know reusing the unused
bits of a double but wait you know we'll
see we'll see what happens there but
yeah so we tend to be 32-bit which means
we have a limited address space for each
each process this I call this the cake
view so you can kind of see how memory
usage grows and you think harm somebody
must be leaking here but actually over
the day I'm going to be caching more and
more data so this may be actually be
normal graze I management layer blue is
our instant messaging system the blue
and the yellow and Victoria the orange
and the other ones are actually I
started running these metrics viewers
and then gradually loaded those up with
with with data so again we can get a
really good understanding of how our
system on the desktop is behaving as a
whole when we want to drill down into
where memory usage is the talk I gave
last year which is actually on YouTube
is how we can do live profiling of
memory usage within within a process and
we end up getting these histograms and
trees that actually show you the call
stacks that actually use them and make
the most memory allocations so if you're
interested in that kind of thing please
have a look at the the talk there
use a responsiveness so how do we
measure you know this this concept of
slowness and actually something that
we've we've really settled on is that
what's the thing you first do when you
trying to see how responsive your
network is you run ping right so
actually pinging the UI thread is a
really good way of understanding how
ready the UI thread is to do new work
and we use that a lot because you know
if the UI thread isn't is busy doing
something else then it can't respond to
a key press or a mouse click or a mouse
move or a mouse hover or any of these
any of these kind of things so actually
having the UI thread ready to do new
work as often as possible is a really
good way of ensuring a good user
experience obviously there's other
factors you know how long it takes to do
a net request and so on how long it
takes you a service to respond but what
users are really looking for is they
want something to happen as soon as they
interact with the system you know even
if it's not the full thing they're
looking for it just has to feel
responsive and so you know how do we how
do we measure these measure these these
kind of things and how do we really
understand what's going on that might
slow down that that the threads that
matters such as the DOI thread it's kind
of what I just said they're actually so
here's a very quick example this is that
instant message system and you know I'm
typing here and it feels jerky so what's
a what you know why is that how can I
actually analyze that the thing you saw
at the the yeah one of the is we can
look at the JavaScript levels so because
we're embedding chromium we can actually
use the chrome dev tools inspector to
see what's going on in the JavaScript
world so this is very good for sort of
you know nice quiet analysis in our own
time when you you know you have the you
know no distractions you can really
understand what's going on at that level
it doesn't really help us at the native
level so we have this tool built into
the terminal which allows us to see
things like you know what kind of work
is going on here
chromium work towards the top the the
the yellow is chromium work the blue is
data layer work down here we are
measuring the yellow triangles are
actually basically this ping time to the
UI thread and you can see where the
keyboard was stuttering it's because
this is a one second actually the scale
here and for each of these little charts
and you can see that there were a
significant delays in the UI thread the
red are actually timer latency so I I
fired some timers or queued some timers
but they fired late because on Windows
timers are the lowest priority thing
they only fire when there's no other
work to do so seeing how late timers are
is also a great indication
/ of whether we're too busy so this can
show us you know the points where we're
actually causing the UI to feel bad for
users and really drill down there how do
we actually do timing in the UI thread
this is just a nice trick which I
thought I'd just quickly show you well
we've got a few minutes so this is a
very typical way of timing some work
Rai principles you have a little scoped
guard that when it's constructed starts
timing something when it's when it goes
out of scope it stops timing and you do
some work within that maybe you have
different kinds of work in some
enumeration that I'm going to I'm going
to do want to measure what does the
implementation look like I probably got
a little stack although it probably
wouldn't be built using a stack because
that's actually a deck inside maybe some
handcrafted little thing and I'm going
to just have the vector of timers which
start timing and stop timing and so I
can measure different kinds of work what
does one of these timers actually look
like
this is actually one something that I
just think is a really neat trick done
by one of the members of my team in
London so this is a timer that can be
called from one thread but observe from
another thread so I can I can have the
UI thread running and separately I can
come in and say how busy are you right
now
whether you're currently doing some work
or not so we have this simple data
structure which just has a level which
protects against recursion so I can
actually start timing the same kind of
work recursively and stop it without
with the only measure at the acid level
but also I have this interesting way of
actually subtracting time now from my
track time when I start timing and
adding it when I when I come back it
seems a little bit odd but if you see
how this works if from my observer sites
and imagine this is running in another
thread that I'm using to observe what's
going on this is just a really neat way
of in one atomic variable tracking how
much time I'm using but also whether I'm
currently timing because if I if I come
in and I'm actually currently timing
something all I've stored is the time
that that work started
so I need to add in my current time now
in order to say well I'm still doing
that kind of work so the amount I've
done so far includes the time now
however if I've done some work but
finished the value is going to be
positive so I can just return it
directly and this is just a you know
maybe this is obvious to everybody I
found it really clever actually just to
be able to have this notion of how much
how much work I'm doing plus whether I'm
doing work so neatly Herald in a you
know in a single atomic and variable so
we actually use this ourselves in in in
this kind of system where we have the
main thread timing things saying what
it's doing in a very lightweight way we
have a monitor thread which basically
writes this data into circular buffers
and then we have a separate UI thread
running this thing which allows us to
observe what's what's going on and it's
relatively unusual to have multiple UI
thread in a set in the same processing
window so but this really works very
well for us something that we do do the
last few minutes is we actually allow
this system to be recorded and it relies
on the fact that the way we create data
is to create objects from our servers is
to avoid round trips so rather than
saying create object and give me a
handle we typically say give me a you
know let's find a free handle without
any kind of round trips and let's use
that handle to create an object and then
send data to that handle so it's purely
push so the nice thing about this scheme
is that not only does it result in no
round trips on the application between
the application and our clients but it's
recordable and we playable and we use
that too for example you know here's a
bunch of interactions running we can be
in recording mode we're not actually
recording what the user does but we're
recording the result and that comes from
our servers - to those particularly user
interactions in such a way is now I can
run in a slightly different environment
here which is running a different
executable but embedding the same
chromium the same data layer and so on
and actually replay at different speeds
in different versions of software so
actually this kind of gives us
a lot of free integration testing
because we can just record all these
things that are that are going on and
replay them through profilers through
our test systems to really understand
how our systems are behaving in these
different scenarios last piece in my
last three minutes webassembly who's
heard of webassembly most people
probably who's used webassembly for you
is is in my team course he seized it
whoever sam is interesting i actually
heard about webassembly first really
this time last year as I said when Addie
was talking about it and when be honest
rostered was here doing the keynote last
year he I just happened to bump into him
in the bar which is a real privilege and
I asked him about webassembly expecting
him to kind of poopoo the idea and so no
no no new platform for C++ fantastic
really really interested so you heard it
here first this conference that he said
that and it's just been a really
intriguing journey we've actually
started to really look into this you
know how can we bring c++ you know
mature complex c++ into the the browser
environment and yeah i just wanted to
touch on a couple of things that we
we've been doing so what is web assembly
it's a binary instruction format for a
stack base virtual machine it's very
fast it's very compact it's close to
machine code and it's pre optimized
secure runs in the same sandbox as
JavaScript and it standard it is
currently supported by all the major
browsers it's portable and you know you
can actually target or you can actually
bring in code from different languages
and run them in any of these browsers so
for C++ there's a there's a tool suite
called in scriptum which generates this
thing called a wesen bundle and for
something like rust there is wesen pack
which generates the same the same bundle
and bytecode system around it in detail
all the C++ tool train looks a bit like
this it's using clang and all of the
LLVM so this is credible powerful you
know industry standard tool chain no
there's nothing you know there's no
throw away and sort of prototype about
this this is this is real and the end
result through this is something that
could be hosted directly in the
JavaScript engine and it brings in
actually if you need it there's a whole
sort of POSIX runtime to allow you to
use this kind of in the confines of the
sandbox obviously how do we hook up to
it you know this is our normal
production desktop system the
experiments we've been doing involve
actually taking the entire data layer
pipeline running it through these this
toolset and producing and the western
version of this directly running inside
the JavaScript engine and get some
benefits dynamic download obviously
efficient binding and the actual binding
layer we've done some benchmarks as
you'll see and it kind of opens up a lot
of intriguing possibilities of sort of
blurring the lines between what should
be in JavaScript what should be in C++
and we're thinking you know there's you
know everything from calculations to
maybe taking pieces of our UI layer that
do some complex transformations on the
for the Dom maybe they they belong in
this world maybe you know charting
packages you know the calculations for
those belong in this this layer how you
actually hook this up together from the
Java stream of C++ if you have to you
know make use of some macros currently
the guys here and my team who are kind
of dotted around have been actually
using a lot of modern C++ very edit
templates index sequences on tuples and
so on to actually automate this whole
process I don't understand this stuff I
had a slide on it but I thought I'm too
scared to talk about it so find the
bloom where guys if you want to
understand how this this works but it's
allowed us to build a generic binding
layer that can target web assembly
bindings v8 JavaScript bindings Python
bindings and so on
for our for our c++ and we're actually
contributing this back to the
inscription focus so they can actually
make this more generally available
performances is very interesting what we
found is worst case is where we're doing
heavy c++ computation work but only 40%
slower than native C++ running on the
same hardware
so it's within the order an order of
magnitude so it's not ultimate
performance but it's close enough for
many scenarios which I find really
intriguing the best case is actually
where we doing a lot of Martian across
the boundary we've actually found that
the boundary between JavaScript and wasm
is actually more efficient than the
current boundary between native C++ and
JavaScript so it's very very practical
you know this is a very intriguing sort
of world we're living in now what's not
what's quite nice is that something we
actually sponsored on the JavaScript
world was this was a new data type
called big int to allow us to have long
length integers in JavaScript you know
particularly financial people you know
have sometimes very large numbers
they're dealing with a profit and loss
they want full precision on these
integers javascript used to not support
that to big int last week I noticed a
tweet from one of the web assembly team
this this guy is actually using that to
actually implement marshalling in my 64
for web assembly so it's quite nice that
it you know these these worlds are sort
of colliding yeah a bunch of references
and we a couple of our web assembly
folks are on Twitter if you follow them
and see who they are T or you'll get in
you'll get in with a whole web assembly
ecosystem there's some you know really
interesting work going on there so in
conclusion couple minutes over sorry
about that
I know it's lunch time it's possible to
leverage modern open-source software in
conjunction with specialized custom
components to build a high-performance
reliable desktop front-end for what at
certain what our clients consider is a
mission mission-critical data service C
plus a JavaScript can be played it can
be made to play very nicely together and
but in order to do that and in order to
make efficient C++ systems on the
desktop you do need to pay attention to
detail something that seemed plus plus
is obviously great for helping us do and
you just have to have a real
understanding of your system behavior
and by how'd you do that you add in
comprehensive metrics and as I say
webassembly hints at a very intriguing
future
you know maybe our system will run in a
browser one day and won't actually need
a lot of this custom sort of stuff
around that but you know interesting
times thank you so much for coming along
I hope that was mildly interesting for
all of you I'm happy to answer any
questions but please go and have lunch
thank you
[Applause]